[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're gonna share with each
other and with you I winter breaks what
the heck happened on our winter breaks
cuz we weren't together
I'm happen to you because you sound
different you know well yeah I'll kick
it off that I think that you know when
we go on our breaks and we do stuff
separate that your biscuits is the place
where we come back together
yeah can we share in fact just give each
other an update just a second ago I was
telling you about something that I was
going to tell you about and I was like
dropping my audio out as I was telling
you so that I couldn't that I would wait
to tell you now it's like I didn't
notice what do you mean dropping you I
was basically like saying use those oh
you know the equivalent I was like and
then there's someone's Oh have looser
songs oh you know oh you were you were
editing yourself so you could tell me
for reals now right yes sir that's what
we're gonna do but I do want to say next
week we're gonna start it next week
we're gonna start something that how
would you even describe I know I doubt
what we're gonna do well yeah we're
going to we're going to we're going to
devote a number of episodes to to a
topic that we've been it just in the
back of our minds there's been something
that's just been percolating for maybe
four years and and I mean the thing that
we're gonna talk about for you know it's
been a lifetime a lifetime decades we're
gonna share about some stuff that we've
never shared before with whenever with
any audience public so we've decided
that we want we want to talk about it
here on your biscuits next week and
funny that's funny man I know that's
just tease but it's a big tease that's
what you got to do in this business link
and I'm looking at my watch because I'm
seeing from a heart rates going up I
didn't hold on you know I'm kind of
gathering my thoughts but they're not
really great has gone up at weird times
we were
something the other day just like having
an ascot discussion amongst like four
people and all of a sudden you got your
alarm I was like what yeah like I didn't
even say what it was but you you knew
that it was an abnormal heart right yeah
he cuz I've gone off before I think it
has to do with what I'm dealing with so
just just to put a closer on the teaser
and then I'll get back to the heart rate
thing yeah so starting next week for a
few episodes its TBD it's something that
we're gonna that we've we've made the
decision we're gonna talk about and if
maybe even if I didn't if we weren't
saying it right now we might even change
our minds I don't think so no no but now
we're definitely not where we are
committed to this
but first let's catch up on our breaks I
I'm sick now really my friggin winter
break has been bookended by sickness two
distinct types of sickness now the one
that happened on the front side I'm
gonna wait to tell you about because it
was just it was strange and I dunno
about that was it so strange it was so
strange you could not tell me about that
right it's none of those things that
like I but you know what when I listen
to you tell it I'm gonna seem like I've
never heard of that you don't have to do
that but it's yeah it was just so
strange it's worth hearing twice right
sure I mean this version will be a
little bit embellished because you've
had time and then on the if I can't
remember it I mean I I thought that it
was putting my vacation in jeopardy and
it was but then I was able to go on my
vacation which was you know enjoying the
holidays here in Los Angeles with my
immediate family and then we went to
Mammoth Lakes Mammoth Mountain is it
Mammoth Lakes right yeah it's where you
went last year to go skiing usually
followed in your foots just say Mammoth
while went imagers who have been there
one time say Mammoth Lakes and let's see
we came back on a Sunday and in the the
previous Saturday my last day of skiing
I came down with the sickness that now
man I hope I'm getting over I hope I'm
not getting it but it all having come
back to the office I've heard that a lot
of people have
had this I mean it's just a head cold
some people have had like bronchitis
some people had other things Christie
had it before vacation I didn't then
Lando had it and then I got when Linda
was just getting over it dadgummit gave
it to me yeah it makes you hate him done
it and so now and I will say it's like
the worst head cold I have ever had the
worst sore throat I have ever had in my
life I need to wear like a mask and III
didn't have a fever and I'm I'm almost
positive it wasn't strep throat I didn't
go to see anybody because I'm stubborn
but um and I did see gradual improvement
but my throat was hurting so bad I mean
it was like almost in tears kind of like
pain like that was probably strep throat
and then I was like you know what like a
sore throat there let's go get robbed at
that painful
I'd better totally strep throat better
to make me feel better it was usually
resolved itself well there was no fever
in it sometimes it turns into a deadly
disease well that's what happens would
strip I went to got ramen and I say you
know what last time I got ramen here you
it's they called it spicy but it was it
so make it a little more spicy no I
wasn't mistake that was a mistake
like and I ate the whole bowl but the
first 15 minutes of eating like I was it
was like I was just I was in torture it
was it was come to find out when you
have like a raw sore throat you don't
want to eat spicy foods y'all well I
don't know what I was thinking you want
any Robin Robin with ramen but non spicy
why did I ask for it more spice it was
so stupid and like you know what ramen
is backwards Mora seems like it would be
you would have just said it was almost
my brain my head is floating above my
neck because it's decongestant I can't
take advantage of a man actually no more
it's what it is backwards before I went
to get Robin I had like a kombucha in
the car cuz you know you've been tell
might all just composure you've been -
I've been drinking so much kombucha I'm
like I'm drinking a kombucha it may have
a matter of a mother in my stomach and I
that that can happen that can't happen I
know I want it you don't want that it's
the only way I can give birth it's like
a yeast ball you're gonna you're gonna
crap out of yeast
what did you think that's gross what
about to taste really gosh well I'm
drinking a kombucha and I'm like I think
I should gargle with this and that was
horrible too like every I think all of
my instant work he's starting 20 20 off
on the wrong foot man with a lot of bad
ideas yeah and I think I'm getting over
it but this morning I got up and you
know you're up for a few minutes and
things start to drain and start to start
to settle and like you can start to
breathe through your nose a little bit
you build a net you hadn't been eddying
any I did some neti pot eating I took
Jade outside and when I'm out there with
her like I had walked down the stairs
out the front I got enough body movement
that like there was some drainage and I
like a hawk double ooh okay and I'm
outside waiting for her to pee and I
spit it out I'm sorry this is gross but
it's just it's what happens and I look
down anyway that's what happens you know
how to tell a lot of things happen to me
today that's not gonna tell you about
well I'm telling you it was bloody but I
could tell by the way that it came up
that it was like it was a it was a weird
consistency so I I bent down and I
picked it up and it was what is wrong
with you
you know if you've like if you like have
a grape and you like squeeze the innards
out of a grape and all you're left with
is the skin of the grape that's what I
spit up but it was blood colored I
freaking spit up a scab the size of a
grape that came out of my nose
you like somewhere in between like the
back of my nose at the top of my throat
where it was hurting the worst
apparently I have a wound yeah you had
strep throat man or something worse
you want to see it I have it right no it
makes me figure that senior picture of
it I didn't know I was gonna pull that
out of my pocket the actual grape I'm
sorry for grossing y'all out but I
actually feel a little better now that
I've told you about it it made me think
of that scene in buddy systems season 2
where I burn your tongue with coffee and
then you can no longer be a professional
food taster and but then at the end
whenever I fail you in the
tournament you start talking funny and
you realize that your tongue scab is
coming off and you pull like a big scab
off of your toes and we originally
scripted it so that when you pulled the
scab off of your tongue you were then
gonna stretch it out and tie it around
your head like a headband that was
that's what we scripted and then we got
it we got notes that it was a little too
much kind of like my story the tongues
gap but it was a alone was enough I
think I'm I think I'm well on my way to
recovery now that I spit out that scab
you've been hanging out with me all
morning yeah I wish you hadn't told me
that
yeah and so feel like [ __ ] and I'm just
you know I just no bones about it all
right but I'm here I'm here for y'all
somehow I've avoided this and it just I
just had this impending sense of doom
because some everybody's gotten sick and
I just haven't gotten sick and I just
yeah you'll get it and you hate it
because it doesn't go away quickly it's
miserable man it's miserable
okay well thanks for that link I feel
like we can go home now I'm sorry it's
you know I can't not be me and I think
there's something to learn from that
well alright but I I'm gonna go back at
what I said again I mean I could
describe some like bodily things that
happened to me today this week that I
just kind of I keep to myself you know I
mean I I appreciate you being vulnerable
and I appreciate you being open about
your experiences but I mean things have
come out of me as well I it's one of
those sicknesses we're just between me
and myself you know what I mean you know
when you're in the worst hope you like
if I ever get better when I get better
because I believe I'm gonna get better
I'm gonna be so grateful for feeling
well you don't I'm never gonna you don't
follow my Twitter apparently that's what
that's what this just represents really
you tweeted about this I tweeted this
very doesn't work right then you get
well and you're like oh yeah I'm just
normal there is no gratefulness yeah you
think about how grateful you're gonna be
when you're not sick that's why when I
get home I'm gonna go find that scab and
I'm gonna take it in sign it's gonna be
a memento you're gonna take it for
granted you're gonna take it for granted
just like everybody
carry on my pocket and yet I'm never
gonna forget I was your vacation
well I mean see how many loogies I
hocked up it was great you know what
actually it was just kind of it was it
was okay yeah I'm gonna tell you all
about my okay I'm gonna tell you all
about my okay break but first we're
gonna let you know that no great Caesar
good mythical morning sweatshirts very
it's kind of cold in this building right
now 68 degrees outside but our our
office they've tried to get the the
heater working and I know you're like 68
why is the heat on well because it's
like 40 in the morning and I want a
little heat well we can't get any heat
in our office i matter you know if you
won't heat go to mythical calm and get
your I just I wear a shirt
I don't need heat there's a flame on the
shirt and if you rub it it gets hotter
and that's the case with all shirts by
the way that's not a special feature of
this one but I thought it seemed like it
well I'd say it's the case with
everything it's just because with
friction you can buy all types of stuff
that mythical calm if you rub a any of
it it's gonna get hotter yeah yeah we're
gonna put that on the banner rub it and
it'll get hot our clothes now with
friction I mean we got all tight we got
necklaces lip balm rub any of it it's
gonna get hotter that's true rep your
boys nickel calm my you it's not you it
wasn't a vacation can I just say that
cuz people these people say how was your
Christmas vacation let's call it a
winter break for you I'm like I and it
wasn't even much of a break oh I don't
know how to do he's a break from work it
was but I'm a workaholic link it was
just something that I which is something
that I already knew but I typically have
December rolls around yeah and there's
like a bunch of things that sort of
buildup oh yeah I'm gonna do that over
break yeah yeah I'll do that over break
oh I'll do that over break and I had a
list of things I think
any of them let me maybe like one thing
and so actually and now you feel bad
about it and that's not right well no I
I had this I discussed this with my
therapist last night actually I'll
discuss it with you
now but this sense of anxiety that was
building because I wasn't getting to the
things and I was like oh what's gonna
happen is brakes gonna get over be over
and then I'm gonna have all the stuff
that I gotta do right at the top of the
year I don't want to do that and I'm
anxious about it that's I mean yeah and
that's what happened to me when I got
back yesterday into the office that's
why my my my watch went off my heart
rate went to the roof for a second
because we were just talking about
something that I felt like that we were
losing control well the thing that I
realized yesterday is when we had a
conversation about it that's when I
started feeling better because it
started feeling like okay now things are
actually happening and like now people
are saying well I'm gonna do this and
I'm gonna do this and you're gonna do
this and it's like yeah what you did
Lera T yeah yeah you and no no work was
done I'm good let me just be very clear
no work was actually done it was just
meetings I'm good at just pretending
that there's nothing to be done until
you bring it up and gain clarity and
start to feel better what you're doing
is you're transferring all the stress to
me that's what happened but I also I
love my family let me be clear about
this but when you are the one in the
family who has moved away and you come
back you there you got to you got to see
everybody and you and you and you got to
see everybody kind of like in your time
ends up kind of getting scheduled and
it's not necessary laxing about it it's
not like going on a vacation is what I'm
getting at and so it doesn't have the
same sort of emotional effect that
vacation has you going somewhere I mean
I just took my jacket off don't let me
distract no you dressed like you're
going somewhere oh you got an interview
I thought if I put on a button-up it
would make me feel better and seem less
sick
I'm freaking glassy-eyed and tail droopy
you know I'm just trying I'm trying to
I'm trying
to muster some sort of reason to go on
if you are going to an interview I
suggest that I just don't do that I'll
do that but Jesse and I did have a
little bit of a break so we of course we
were in North Carolina for almost two
weeks seeing everybody and the good news
is that everyone's close together so and
I stay in the same place so it's like
when you guys go back you have to go to
all these different places so we don't
to do that North Carolina but we were
there like I said almost two weeks and
then right after Christmas Jesse and I
decided well we already decided this
we're gonna go get a little time away
we're gonna go to Ashfield leave the
kids which is like Nashville without an
inn and it's the place that if you live
in Los Angeles and you say you're from
North Carolina
they're like Asheville it's like the
only thing that people know about North
Carolina in LA is Asheville and cool
spot it's because it's super cool but
notes you don't know anybody who's lives
there but it's a cool place to go went
at depth at Grove Park in a big old
historic hotel with a giant spa got my
massage on except you stayed there yeah
and really it planned I just let you
left the kids with like I don't even
know listen I lost I lost track I'm not
kidding I lost track of my children both
of them but they were in multiple days
they were under care of relatives I
assume so okay well how was that right
I'm not joking about this especially the
15 year old like at one point I saw him
and then like six days later I saw him
again I was like are you brushing your
teeth like I just are you taking care of
yourself who's feeding you
I can guarantee he looks better than you
do I mean you know like you rolled off a
look at your hair man is every when you
went home did everybody have to say you
have to give an assessment interestingly
no I think they just a little worried
everybody just kind of no longer made
eye contact there's a little worried and
won't cave mention it yeah you know what
I saw yesterday I was like took my
breath away
I've lost well thankfully I've lost a
little control it's it actually has
become it was a burden I will say I
don't wanna talk about my hair
it all really but the only thing I'll
say is it has become a burden you fit in
a Nashville we have we've got mountain
burden stage it doesn't seem like you're
you're burdened at all and I thought
that was the point it takes a lot of
time to make it look like I don't care
okay
so I we went to Asheville and you may
remember from we had a great time to us
you may remember last year if you happen
to be a long time to listen to a student
of my Instagram I'm in 2020 I'm not
gonna use the term follower for any of
my social media I'm just gonna use the
term student and so I I got a belt with
my name on it last year this is what
we're talking about yeah okay and I
remember that yes you know I'm wearing
that belt all year every single day with
a few exceptions I wore that belt the
Matt name on it you hit me about
November last year you know what I
should do a belt again this year and
then it was just like I should do a belt
every year a belt every year should be
my new thing do you know anybody else
who does that I saw something I probably
do but they don't think it's worth
sharing I saw what they call some white
space in the belt every year you know
area so okay so uh I thought I was gonna
go down to overo Street where they
that's where the guy made my belt last
year here in LA
not Asheville but I you know I failed to
do that because of all the stuff we had
to do and whatnot then I was anxious
about that and didn't leave it on me and
but there was a very fine leather shop I
would give him a shout out but I already
forgot the name oh it's it's next to the
early girl eatery in Asheville which is
also a really good place to eat good
spot yeah Jenna knows about that we ate
there we can send up in silence for
commercial cake commercial Kings well a
couple doors down from that is this
leather place and the dude has a large
assortment of antique belt buckles along
with all the leathery that he will do I
don't know if that's a word I didn't
read many of the signs but I was like
hell yeah I'm gonna
belt buckle this time not just a belt
I'm gonna get a belt with my name on it
and a belt buckle ladies and gentlemen
if you're watching this you'll have to
wait if you're listening but this is my
new belt put the microphone up to it
sounds like that's a wooden belt buckle
or the desert scene I'll try not to show
any skin tuck in your sweatshirt tuck in
the sweatshirt I'm gonna take it off and
short let you examine it
hold on this is training this is
bringing back flashbacks and my
babysitter's husband when he come home
from work so he would just come over
more and take off his belt this is a
little bit different now
Paul's tailored custom channels and belt
sounds about custom sandals so now you
may remember visit let me can I describe
what I've seen because there's
frustration
okay what Rhett has taken off from his
waist and as well it is a warm belt
matter of fact it's hot to the touch on
the back of the buckle it's a metal
buckle I've been thinking real hard and
it's it's got it's got wood in there and
I think that could be Jasper
I think it's wood it's wood man there's
a saguaro after the wood section there
is a freaking Setting Sun over the
Monument Valley ask desert formation
it's a desert scene on an oval belt
buckle on a leather belt and let me tell
you about the design on the belt I can't
remember the name of this what this is
but sometimes called sage is called
tooling now last year it was really HAP
hazard and yet it really quick this guy
had to mail me this belt because it's
gonna take me you know I can't finish
this today because this is like this
thing they like roll it through this
thing and it's got this it's sort of
this cactus theme but then when you get
to the middle let's check out what I did
there
it seems that Rhett has commissioned the
writing of some thing it's hard to see
because it's a no it's an Old English
but what does it say like Zoe Zoe Zoe
Zoe Zoe
oh no no no Z Oh Rhett so 2000 any Rhett
20 that's right I got a I got a belt
with the year and my name on it and that
is what I'm doing from here on out
ladies and gentlemen and then my kids
can fight over daddy's belt collection
when I die so it says 20 Rhett 20 I'm
not gonna give it to both of them what
year is it
how many Rhett 20 in my will is going to
say a fight to the death between my sons
is how you determine who gets the belt
collection so when you die you won't
want to be R sub 2 then also die and the
time to get your belt cuz son that loses
the fight is buried with me with no belt
there's so many belts man just divide up
the belts this is this let me tell you
right now I didn't
this belt got pricey real quick the one
in Olvera Street went 40 bucks I want to
do a custom but I don't even care I want
to know how much you pay for it well you
got the thing that gets it up there is
the belt buckle
did he make $79 for the belt buckle it's
but it's a custom it's an it's antique
he just he has these he found that from
some was some man wore this that's been
on some other man's pubic area for a
long time well up just above it a man
who wore this is like driven cattle
across expanses with Billy Crystal you
know I'm saying this is this is the real
deal man
you don't know I like to believe it who
was that guy's name is city slickers
Pappy not Pat no curly curly yeah Jack
Palance right he won an Oscar for that
what a great movie doesn't really hold
up why originally with the kids maybe he
just came out during holdups anyway I'm
not saying he was gay I'm saying he just
appeared
you could also be gay I don't know are
care
but anyway that was the highlight for me
honestly was getting a new belt I mean I
got to say just in perspective the best
part of my Christmas break was getting a
new belt I feel a little naked without
it but I'm gonna see how I can see if I
can sit yeah don't stand up because you
pay it to stay where they are when we
got back I felt like I needed a little
bit of a of an actual break and so I
went skiing and Big Bear with Shepherd I
was going to I was I was been skiing and
you felt like you couldn't get left
behind well if that's how you want to
see it the way I saw it was we're going
skiing as a family in a and we're going
to Mammoth in the near future and it's
like you kind of want to get you get
your ski that's back yeah but locking it
up going actually to Mammoth with
friends and so aunt got a concussion and
had to not ski long story he's fine but
so Shep and I just went just two of us
skied for a couple of days had a great
time I did see that on your story cuz I
was I was back in the real world then
being sick and doing nothing except
bedridden looking at you
gallivanting down the mountain really
trying to see if you could ski better
than me is where I was trying to assess
having gone for five days in Mammoth I
think I could pry ski better than you
okay I'm just I've got a lot more skiing
experience I was that is true but I
don't like all spring breaking last year
yeah was six days of skiing you want to
have a ski off ski off well that brings
me my name a time and place my thoughts
about skiing which are it had been two
years since I had been skiing really for
the first time in a long time when I
along with the kids are trying to learn
how to ski you do the black diamond he's
given up the snow boarding no I don't do
that I'm better than you bro are you
telling me you can ski a black diamond
if it's not moguls hell yes
well then you're definitely better than
me I mean because I mean I went up to a
balloon I don't look like I know what
I'm doing but I'm fine I mean I went up
to a blowout of sliding going on not a
lot of real skiing here's what I thought
here's what struck me because I was like
Christie do you want to come ski with us
like we're learning we will have
instructor and she was like no she
basically said you know it's scary and I
was like okay I respect that and then
that's what's fun about I got back I got
out there and um with the kids and we
were all doing well like being
instructed and really getting back into
it after a couple of years but it the
thing that struck me I was seeing like
oh people I was seeing people who were
like rotund like not really people in
shape okay yeah because you're sliding
and the bigger the better I think
but here's the thing I skiing is an
extreme sport you're going down a
mountain on two sticks and for some
reason anybody thinks they can roll up
rent some crap and do it and then
there's and I don't know how old people
and out-of-shape people are doing I
consider myself kind of in shape and
shape enough at my age to like get out
there and look all right but like maybe
I have a heightened sense of mortality
or that I haven't appreciated where
there's a lot more riding on me now you
know your entire career buddy okay for
one so it is scary
I mean you freaking over the side of a
mountain on sticks it's extreme sport
well no no it's not no no no no it's not
an extreme sport wouldn't certain the
ski jumping is an extreme sport skiing
is an extreme sport no it's not you
winter sport if you would go to the top
of the mountain in the summertime with a
mysite ice skate is that you know an
extreme sport mountain bike down this
there's no way anybody could just say
well I've ridden a bike before okay I'm
going down a mountain know what uh hold
on but see no you can it's it's all it's
on a spectrum I could go down a mountain
bike course at a very slow speed I
couldn't do it in a way that is
respectable or actually sporty what I
could break my way down and well this
isn't speaking from experience and I
think I talked about this years ago when
I had my accident or like a downhill
mountain bike course is that that's not
actually true if you get to a certain
steepness like the double black diamond
or a
black diamond of mountain biking you act
the slower you go you're screwed
well but it's not a bank but we're
skiing it listen if you get to a place I
don't do that I do the black diamonds
occasionally when it's like oh when you
kind of need to go down this really
quick black diamond to get to this other
blue and it's not moguls moguls is bad
news for me I got I'm big I got big skis
I I don't like to triple if to think
about a turn is that in order to ski
properly you have to commit and shift
your weight forward down the hill and
all instinct tells you to do is the
steeper it gets lean back more which
immediately causes trouble and you're
you're zooming down the mountain and
you're you could you could die you have
to trust the technique at least in my
understanding to shift your weight
forward over the the leading ski or the
the outer ski and then make a turn and
that is a scary moment like when I was
on a blue well it's very sorry I did it
if I was it's very scary Wiggin out
until you develop the feel to be like oh
I can turn both ways reliably and once
you can turn and stop yourself then you
could pretty much do anything again I'm
not saying I look like I know what I'm
doing it's not like I yeah I've got good
form and I'm not carving I'm definitely
kind of sliding and let it be known I'm
thinking about not getting hurt the
entire time it's not like when I was a
young man and I was just thinking about
what's the most fun thing that I could
do right now yeah yeah what's the most
fun line that I could take down this
mountain it's very much like how can I
not get hurt is that way less hurt is
this way less hurt like to me that's not
going above a blue well but you got it
but you still gotta have a little fun
and once you get there doesn't seem to
be any difference steepness is no longer
becomes an issue when you can turn
without any trouble and that is to get
that yet that you you you'll get there
in like two more days of skiing you know
what you come out with me I'll show you
I mean who has has anyone taught you how
to do like the plant the pole intern
thing like the proper technique for
ivan i watch you know the people with
the full ski suits like one piece that
dude knows what he's doing
even though you can like get one that
says US Ski Team on Amazon I just assume
if you've got one of those you know what
you're doing and I'm gonna get one of
those just so people can say you never
really what happened I got run over by a
guy from the US Ski Team he was totally
out of control
he must have been he was amazing
equipment manager
no yeah I can do it but it's not but
it's yeah it doesn't look smooth and
cool and like pop like I want to get
there because I think there's a Zen
associated with like going up high I
mean I wasn't man with the whole time
with my kids and like we didn't we only
went on a blue once you missed so much
of the mountain I know but I just I
didn't have the technique green and I
didn't want to ditch my kid here's the
problem here's the problem with the
greens too many people in fact when you
go to Big Bear there's there's its
summit snow summit which is the yeah
he's sort of the bigger mountain between
the two you can do there there's this
really long run called summit run and
it's green the whole way and it gets
carved up by all these people and
there's kids and it's like old people
yeah but what we found is if there's a
certain part of the mountain you could
go off sort of its far to the left as
you can get you come down these long
blue runs and then you get back on the
lift and you literally do snow line yeah
and it's like that the eat the people
aren't obstacle we should go man my boys
my boys are getting me off lynnie
Lily's done great but she doesn't really
is she doesn't she's not motivated to
get up the mountain but the three of us
are one of the things that I'll go with
you that in a couple weeks am I now if I
hit well no we've already kind of got
things worked out we're going with a
different family
I thought he invited me guys did you
hear that he was like come with me off
any time any place except the
predetermined time that I'm going skiing
with another family okay you don't want
me to embarrass Jessie when we were in
Asheville when we travel together Jesse
watches trashy reality TV it's just what
she does we don't really watch it any
other time
we have like TLC and Bravo like you know
at home but I don't know if she knows
that and I'm ready to keep it down I
think she thinks that TLC and Bravo only
get broadcast in hotels okay hopefully I
think she doesn't listen to this budget
I can't tell you what's on that what did
you watch well on TLC it's not a
Learning Channel link no one's learned
anything on TLC for many years okay
except how to not behave how to not be
like the people in all the shows that
they okay
but like the house that one in
particular that we watched is 90 day
fiancé you guys know about this mmm
there's a show where well Jesse made fun
of me and tweeted this out because I was
watching it kind of over her shoulder I
get sucked in I'll admit I get sucked
into these things and they go through a
number of different couples and that's
like is it always is one of them always
international and she like thought that
was so funny she had to tweet it because
the whole point of the show is yes it's
someone who's getting married
essentially to get a to get a green card
oh it's not that the love isn't real it
may only reach three months well I don't
know what's the three months because I
think you have to be I think you have to
be is it married for I don't know where
the 90 days comes in you have to be
engaged for at least 90 days like in a
relationship or nowadays to enjoy it
what did what did you what was your
takeaway if it wasn't that my takeaway
was I learned a lot about myself because
I ended up tweeting something like
sometimes I start to think that I'm a
good person and then I realized that I'm
ruthless ruthlessly judging a woman I
don't know for serving pizza rolls at
her wedding
now with the tweet that I wanted to
tweet that Jesse said no you can't tweet
that was sometimes I start to think that
I might be a good person and then I
start having murderous impulses towards
a woman that I don't know for serving
pizza rolls at her wedding so you wanted
to kill somebody
yeah that's what I wanted to talk about
is that when I watch these people would
you like pizza rolls what a hypocrite
no one even served pizza rolls at their
wedding it was the kind of thing that
would have happened on the show it was a
joke okay
okay I found myself wanting to hurt the
people on the show and and just like I
was like where's this entertainment to
me
yeah man somebody who's got so many
opinions about the way people behave you
watch one of these freaking episodes and
you tell me you don't want to kill these
people I'm not I'm saying I probably
would but I wouldn't spend my time
trying to be entertained in that Jenna
you just watch it and you're like what
you can't it's like a train wreck you
can't look away
you just can't but I can't believe some
of those decisions that people make oh
but you know what that tweet that I
actually made that what that was
different
I've got my I've got my this show not
about you rehashing all your tweets no
no no no the thing that I was actually
tweeting about was for weddings which is
a different show I wanted to kill those
people too just to be clear for weddings
this is when four women have a wedding
they each have a wedding they're all
getting married but they attend each
other's weddings as far as the show and
then they rate each other's weddings and
then the winner the best wedding from
the other three women deciding who has
the best wedding gets it like a trip
honey Miller something so the women are
horrible to me and I wanted to kill
three out of four of those women okay
not there's one that was like okay I die
she can go but you you you you wanted to
keep watching I couldn't stop
I couldn't stop sounds anything but I
couldn't stop hating them ie I was just
like I can't do this I can't watch this
these people make me so mad
for the dumb things that the decisions
that they're making is that I mean is
Jesse feeling that way why did she watch
it the same reason anyone watches any
reality television yeah I mean of course
she doesn't get angry it's just like we
watch The Bachelor too you know but she
gets a kick out of it she's not getting
angry I don't know maybe she's more
maybe she's got she's better than me
well we know that she's know she's
getting a kick out of it but you just
get so frustrated with with people
sometimes you're just like I just don't
understand how this person got to be
this person so I think I thought that
they were supposed to make you these
shows feel better about yourself but
it's interesting that it's making you
come to grips to the fact that you are a
bad person
yeah because I think you could just
watch him and just be like well I'm
better than that person oh I'm better
than that person I'm better than that
person I'm glad I'm not that person
I'm better than that person which would
be a pretty easy thing to do but instead
it turned into murderous impulses I
wouldn't actually do it but I just found
it I felt it in my heart and wanted to
tweet it but I'm all I said I couldn't
but now I have and then I don't we don't
vacation cuz I'm on vacation
tweets work for me I but I did in my
draft in my drafts yeah I'm as a
murderous drug just as murderous
impulses in a draft okay I'll cut her
okay I was like I got to go back to that
you're going give all people like they
read it it did remind me that last year
when we went to Sedona at night you may
recall we would watch Survivor having
never watched it we as a family got into
watching Survivor so my plan and
everybody was on board was that we were
gonna do that again this year
oh good there's a dynamic though that
like Lily 16 years old she had a friend
who was also in Mammoth so like the
first night she was like can I spend the
night with my friend and like no you
have to stay here and watch Survivor
with your family yeah so I was like yes
tonight you can be away you know so it's
like we're in this weird flux as a
family where it's like you can't but you
can't hold it together you guys can't
hold it together all the time
so you choose your battles that went out
the door but what we did do in the wake
of the rise of Skywalker and something
about Harrison Ford made a connection to
Indiana Jones and I think Christy was
like we should watch Indiana Jones
because the kids hadn't seen it and so
what they hadn't seen their native Jones
any of them I have okay Wow all the
things I haven't seen I have and I got a
special place in my heart for the second
one Temple of Doom because it is the
first movie I ever remember watching in
a theater you know I'd visit my day I
had visitation with my dad or whatever
you call it he wasn't that in prison
though what's it called when you're you
don't live with your dad and you have to
go stay with him
hanging out yeah I was hanging out with
my dad there isn't the tourism name it's
not in custody what's that name I don't
know any what might be visitation you
might be right but it just sounds like
you're visiting a prison a person in
prison I mean this was I think it was
1983 when this movie came out can you
check that I guess I mean maybe it was
hell of doom yeah yeah I mean it
could've been even if it's 86 that I
would have been eight years old it was
the first movie I saw in the theater and
I was he wanted to see it and I guess he
thought I would like it but I was
terrified 84 so yeah I was six years old
because of the heart scene yeah and I
did reaches in there and pulls out a
beating heart it scared the crap out of
me but it was special and I wanted to
share that with my kids especially Lando
who I told him to close his eyes so we
watched all four of them and let me tell
you the first three are freaking magical
the fourth one it has Shia LaBeouf and
you know I'm really into him now right
big fan ahead but you're you're in
society you're gonna shout Shia LaBeouf
right now but fully matured not like you
know too much CGI pain Shia LaBeouf the
first three are all I think temple to do
is my favorite but we had a blast
watching these and it's the first two
are just they're all amazing I mean III
think they're my you know my favorite
movies and I was just reminded that your
your favorite movies in you kids haven't
seen him until now yeah we've been doing
it was fun man it's fun watching that
but yes about that that was the big
thing for me and I think you
no coming back I'll tell you this story
that I got to tell you the medical story
before I went but just concluding
because I kind of feel the same way you
do in terms of like give it I last night
I told Christy I was like you know now
that we're back from our vacation what
do we what do we think about it what do
we learned what do we want to do
differently next year because this is
our second year of being in in LA for
for Christmas and the thesis is were
building our own traditions and yeah and
I had this feeling of like like you said
at the top you're like I was you know it
was I always wanted to be great and be
like the best Christmas ever but it
wasn't it was okay but then the more we
thought about it I realized we actually
started to talk about and I wonder if
you and Jesse ever talk about this it's
like as the kids get older we want to
start building expectations and
traditions things that we are going to
keep doing there's an expectation so
that when they go off to school or go
off to their own lives and they're
starting to date people and get engaged
and whatever they're gonna do that
they're gonna want to come back and do
these things with us every year so it's
like okay this is what we do for the
holidays then after the holidays we
would always take a trip you know we've
done it two years in a row it doesn't
really matter how great the trip is as
long as there's an expectation that like
especially when kids start leaving I was
like man I'm I'm sure it will be special
when Lilly's been off at college and
then she comes back and like the boys
haven't seen her since she went to
college like she didn't come home for
Thanksgiving say you know we got her she
going she's like further away at college
kind of like you know our friend's
daughter who like went up to Oregon and
like they didn't see her until her
sibling didn't see her until she came
back for Christmas and I'm like yeah and
if we're if we're just at home you know
what's gonna happen oh I got these plans
here I got these plans here but like if
we have this expectation that we're
doing some sort of family trip I'm like
I think this can become really special
in that way so I started to feel better
about it then like Lilly and Lincoln
have left the house and like it's just
Lando waiting around so hey I haven't
seen my siblings in months and then
they're coming back and we're doing
something
and I started to feel like you know what
as I as I often conclude about myself I
put so much pressure on the specifics
and on achieving some sort of perfection
that it actually made me feel better to
say okay we're creating space and I
think I've said this before creating an
an opportunity for memories to be made
and that's I think that's the biggest
victory and that's that's the definition
of success if we're together enough
where things good bad and different can
happen that's success especially for
when they get old and all you got to do
to get them to come back when they're
all is go somewhere because they won't
have any money yeah they say it when you
say hey free trip your meals will be
paid for these kids are gonna come back
man they'll be coming back free your
girlfriend coming back for years so
bring my board fruit now if you just say
hey just come back to the house you
gotta you gotta you gotta have a carrot
that's what that's what I'm building
Indiana gentle survivor well well before
you before you tell your medical story
sure oh yeah I want I want to run
something by you that happened to me on
the flight back okay you want a cough
drop nope I don't want to touch anything
that you've been touching alright so
coming back on the flight you know it's
like a five-hour flight five six hour
flight from Raleigh to LA and I I got
this new neck pillow thing and I'm
experimenting with because me and Locker
are taking a very special trip that I'm
havin gonna tell you about until I get
back from it because it's gonna it's a
pretty big moment for me oh but it
requires a long flight and I was like I
want to be able to sleep on the plane
that's months from now yeah I need to
figure out how to sleep on the plane so
I'm gonna test some pillows I don't like
the regular ring the regular doughnut
pillow
I don't like the fact that there's a
pillow behind my neck and I fall all
around there's this thing I don't know
what it is where you it's a break
inside of a blanket and then you wrap it
around your neck and then it's not it
velcros back on to itself
and so you're it's this piece of plastic
it's basically supporting your head and
it got all these reviews on Amazon like
five-star reviews on Amazon you tell
them out a scarf it's a scarf with wale
to embrace okay and it kind of worked I
still ended up waking up a thing la my
knight doesn't feel great but better
than if I had one of those traditional
pillows anyway so I like slept through
the flight attendant coming buying
asking do you want a snack and do you
want to drink or whatever so I wake up
and she's like walking by and I was like
excuse me can I get one of the protein
boxes and a water like this is like the
pate like yeah yeah hey for it right
she's like okay so then another flight
attendant comes back and she hands me
the protein box and I was like thank you
oh and can I also get a water and she
said I've only got two hands oh snap
whoa which I've only got two hands what
this is not even the same person there's
a different person you know it's like oh
and before I could be like I'm not first
of all there are certain people who
might like my brother
as an example yeah he would immediately
clap back yeah but I was just like okay
and then so then Jesse here's this
interaction she's like what was that
why did what you didn't do anything
wrong and then and first of all you
could carry out water in a protein box
with two heads
just FYI yeah cuz one of them's a box
and one of them's a cop well or a bottle
so I Jesse thing goes it gets up to go
to use the restroom and then she comes
back and she says you will not believe
what just happened
what happened she's
that flight attendant was back there
telling another flight attendant about
the interaction that she just had with
you what and she was saying and then he
says could I get a water and I was like
I've only got two hands it's like what
is happening like weird and how is I
don't I hope that's not the end of your
story oh no I don't know what come on
cuz then let me finish your story so
then I got up to quote use the bathroom
but when I went up there and I saw the
woman I said excuse me ma'am my wife
just overheard you retelling the story
that I was also talking to my wife about
and we can't make sense to the fact that
you're so upset that I asked for a water
eat after you've delivered me a box said
it seems totally reasonable to then ask
for you to go back and get a watch and I
don't ask for a water even though the
other one to another flight at than that
so what did I do wrong what can I do
differently next time so that you won't
come back and spill the tea to your
comrades up here at the front this
problem baffle the problem with that
kind of behavior is that that's the kind
of thing that like escalates quickly the
next thing you know somebody turning the
plane around like a US Marshal like
sticks of syringe in your neck and you
fall down like you know I'm saying like
yeah it's like that's the kind of thing
that happens because if were you rubella
on iron anybody puts you on a like a
phone video they're like that dude is
crazy
all right look at his hair yeah and so I
was just like I'll let it slide I mean
the other woman did bring me water and
it was great
I'm angry good I wanted to say I want to
get angry about your last story I feel
murderous thoughts there you go
now I want I feel like murdering 2020s
woman who's just gonna she only wants to
be engaged for 90 days so she can I
don't know for some sort of citizenship
thing and that's not even the right show
pizza rolls I'm confused
so a few days before the holidays really
start getting going
I hold on no this is the day after
Christmas because two days later we were
gonna go to Mammoth
and I wake up y'all I think it was
before Christmas cuz I remember talking
to you Chris wasn't Eve yeah that's
right it was the Christmas Eve Eve I I
did the thing I rarely do which is talk
to you over break cuz I heard something
happened to me because I was concerned
ain't you ask me I think Jesse asked you
told you to ask me no she didn't have
some sort of empathy no your wife texted
Jesse yeah and said something that was
strange about your health situation and
I called you you know ninety minutes
later listen you know what I I'm glad
that you asked me how I was doing and
I'm sorry that I assumed that your wife
put you up to it is that really how it
happened it is how I have cool-cool
tell your story man so whatever freaking
day it was I'm in a murderous frame
right now man it's your fault if I'm
coming down on you if I'm taking it out
on you it's your fault yeah I woke up
because the room was spinning I didn't
wake up and find that the room was
spinning I woke up because with my eyes
shut I was tumbling through some sort of
space I opened my eyes and I'm laying on
my side and the room is spinning at this
rate Wow
what mouth proud if you're on a carousel
it's like if the kids on one of those
merry-go-rounds and adult is running as
hard as they can
pushing it around and you're the kid
that's fast fast but depends on how big
it is what the radius of the
merry-go-round did mister trivial
acceleration is dependent on the radius
not if you're sitting in the middle of
the merry-go-round you're right about
that all right
so he'll wake up and it's like I didn't
have anything to drink the night before
I just has no hangover type of a spin
and I sat up and I just sat there and as
I was sitting there I'm slowly falling
over on the bed
you know it's just like if you get real
dizzy you you can't sit up straight and
then finally I got still enough that the
room did stop and I'd slept later than
Christie she wasn't even up there so I
got my phone and I was like I need you
to come up here because I feel weird but
I had to pee really badly so then I got
up and I slowly walked to the toilet and
I sat down to pee not because I always
sit down to pee which I do but because I
really had to this time and I I I
basically fell off the toilet because
the room started to spin again mm-hmm
and then Christie came up there and I
told her well actually I made my way
downstairs because she never got the
text and I'm like explaining her what
happened because it would just go into a
spin and but it wasn't constant it was
like at certain times so I got a made my
way down there just fine and I'm like
telling her she's like well I got up
this morning I was really sick never
Google home I'm broadcast to the house
yeah I do so I could like do an intercom
thing like help me the room is spinning
yeah you say I'm not gonna say the thing
H Google uh-huh broadcast help me the
room is spinning okay and then it'll do
that I do it all the time I'll do that
next time because then hopefully
somebody would have cover on it and she
was like well I was really sick this
morning like it wasn't good I think I
have food poisoning I'm like you know
what I guess I we ate the same thing the
kids ate something different well I just
we thought I had food poisoning so I
like Google like dizziness associated
with food poisoning you can find some
link to anything so like I thought
that's what it was it happened a few
more times serious food was back and I
was like I'm gonna go back and lay down
in bed and when I laid down it happened
a little bit but I went to sleep and I
woke up with a room spinning same thing
happening again
Chrissy starts talking to a friend of
hers Katie who's like you know it links
that vertigo a lot of my relatives have
it you should try she mentioned some
maneuver which
later it turns out was something called
the Epley maneuver so we're like
googling this thing it actually was the
next day that we had this conversation
with her we didn't uncover this maneuver
you had a day of spinning I had a day of
spinning and a night of it
gosh and and I was like looking up can't
sling my reservations at mammoth like it
I was thinking well what if I when do I
start getting penalized if I if I cancel
an Al vs. cancel later how much more is
it gonna cost me because I'm like
there's no signs of this going away you
could have been a guy who spins down the
mountain though and we were googling a
bunch of stuff but then the next day
when we googled this it was so
interesting was like okay I'll get this
is a maneuver that you can just try on
your own there's like physical
therapists who have YouTube videos that
tell you how to do it but the theory
behind it is in your inner ear which of
course is a center of equilibrium along
with like parts of your brain you've got
these if you seem the model of the inner
ear you've got these different loops
that come off of it right these like
different tunnels which are filled with
I don't know imma call it liquid I
believe it is and it's these different
tubes that come that are oriented in
different directions that magically in
both of yours keep you it's miraculous
when you look at how this mechanisms
work and then the assertion is that if a
crystal which apparently there are
crystals in another part of your ear
that are supposed to be there if a
crystal we're not not not New Age
crystals know just like a particle not
like something that Gwyneth Paltrow
would insert nerve Aegina like a not a
no not a goop dildo I don't know I'm
talking about what they would call a
crystal makes his way into one of these
canals where it is not supposed to be oh
then every time that crystal moves in
the canal you the room starts spinning I
was like this is wild you grow these
crystals as an adult or like they're
there as a baby I don't understand I I
don't
the they seem to imply that the crystal
got in the wrong place not that the
crystal existed
and these are in the few videos that I
watched okay I only want to know how to
fix it I didn't really care about real I
hire weird people I have yes I just want
to make sure I've got crystals it this
Epley maneuver is wild because it's a
series of movements that then manipulate
the crystal to go on a nice little
trajectory around the loop using gravity
using gravity to then exit that the
canal that the tunnel now this feels
like the kind of thing that who do you
watch a YouTube video yeah and you do it
I got really excited knowing you think
you know while it's happening when you
see the thing being performed on someone
you're like this is not going to work
especially when it's this simple okay
you sit up on your bed and then you lay
down such that then your head is tilted
back like if I'm sitting up here
straight I'm gonna look up like put my
chin in the air so that my head is
angled back I mean you you lay back and
then you tilt your head to the right or
the depending on which year it's in I'll
just say I don't even know which is
which but like you turn to the right 45
degrees and then look back 30 degrees or
something like that did you have a
protractor and that no no protractor we
have a program Missy was there like
holding my head cuz I showed her the
video excuse me I thought I had another
scab oh gosh
so you lay back you look in this one
direction in the room starts to spin you
hold it until the room stops spinning
what really yes and that did happen and
that happened just a little bit the room
moved just a little half spin and then
there's three positions the second
position is instead of looking to the
right 45 degrees with your head still
tilted back then you you turn your head
to the opposite looking 45 degrees to
the left head has still draped over the
end of the bed I know it may not make
sense but you know watching YouTube
video then the room starts to spin again
ie the crystal has moved
and you have to let the room stop
spinning for the crystal can settle in
this new position crystals man and then
the third one is while you're looking to
the left then you take your whole body
and you roll over on your side while
keeping that same angle 45 degree angle
of looking to the left so now you're
looking straight down at the floor and
laying on your left side
what is your wife doing at this point
she's turning me over and trying to like
take the vantage point of like yes she's
my protractor are you both naked we're
both naked yes we're making love I
forgot that part you need to be in a
constant state of not right that's how
you get that crystal when I turned over
that to that third position I every the
world unhinged what it was spinning so
aggresses
I started want this dad it was so scary
dude hey ice imal taneous leaf l
encouraged because something was
happening it was going according to I
was going on in a plan and the room was
spinning so aggressively that I started
moaning uncontrolled oh wow oh those are
the noises I was actually making oh and
I thought I was going to vomit it was so
bad and it took oh it took way too long
for my taste for the room to stop
spinning but you have to hold away for
the crystal and then you sit up and on
the edge of the bed and this one
particular youtube video I saw which no
one else afterward told me that I had to
do what this was but the physical
therapist in this video I was like and
then at this point make sure for the
next 24 hours that you don't look up and
so he recommended that you put on a neck
brace yep and I wanted to follow
everything to a tee I didn't have a neck
brace so I took a towel yeah in some
packaging tape and I folded a towel up
around my neck and then I took packaging
tape and I taped the thickness of a neck
brace now look it up and Christie's like
calling the physical therapist
is gonna come into the office and has
agreed to see me and make sure that
we're doing this right because when it
was over I still didn't feel good I
still felt really discombobulated but it
was a spinning it wasn't spinning and
then it so a few hours later we're
supposed to go in to see her but I
didn't I thought that she was coming to
the house so I go downstairs the
doorbell rings and it's a I never met
this therapist but it's an it's an Asian
lady I knew that Kristi taught me so I
go to the door with my neck brace on and
I open the door and there's an an Asian
lady there and I say to her I say thank
you so much for coming please come on in
she said oh no it's fine I'll stay right
here and I'm thinking you you can't do
the maneuver on me right here but I
didn't say that
and then I saw that she had a name tag
and it said so in Judy so-and-so Forest
Lawn Cemetery and she was trying to sell
her a grave plot and I'm like you're
that bad we got a man with crystals you
know what happens 30% of the time the
life is falling apart I opened the door
to get treatment and a woman tries to
sell me a grave plot yeah
and she's like guy he's got on a towel
neck brace like him because this is a
good start
he's close to death he's definitely at
death finally got rid of her and I sat
back down and we we went to the buy a
plot that I was like oh your salon is a
classy place to go I'm like I'm gonna I
want to be incinerated in the most but
you can still have I wanna phone I want
to find like an environmentally most
environmentally friendly way to do it
which may not exist yet but that's a
talk for another time okay I go to the
therapist physical therapist she was
kind enough to see me and she did the
same maneuver and it was did it all
again yeah but nothing was spinning but
oh yeah cuz you had already done and you
know what what we did worked I was just
so anxious and I believe that it wasn't
going to work
yeah this reminds me I was just too
uptight and that's what she told me and
then she sold me a special pillow oh she
did yeah kind of like yours but you know
what I'm learning something about like
husks
learning something about you do you
remember when you got an or be stuck in
your ear yeah it wasn't really an or be
stuck of my there was for a moment I
yeah there was in there was much
consternation because I believed it was
still in there yeah yeah you've got a
thing about thinking that things are
still in your ear and they're not listen
you're the hypochondria I am
but when nothing's wrong with you you
believe that the world is crumbling I'm
not an acute hypochondria but then when
something is wrong with me and it gets
better I believe that it hasn't gotten
better right it's a different type of
hypochondria okay then that's it it's
that maneuver a shout-out to mr. mrs.
Eppley who invented that maneuver it's
like magic think about all think about
how they had it like I waited I suffered
a day in a night knowing about this
maneuver cadavers so how do they figure
it out I just look at the ear and think
about physics it yeah it's awesome
now I got the rec this week's really
geometry breakfast maybe rec baby one
two three four I'll keep it simple my
rec is remember the Epley maneuver when
the world starts spinning around you
because it's crazy remember I remember
that it exists just remember that it
exists you don't even have to learn it
just know that it's there a lot more
complicated than the Heimlich the
Heimlich don't watch it YouTube video
when that when you need to do that just
do it Eppley definitely you can take
your time yeah that's true that's true I
recommend now learning the Heimlich
maneuver let's all do that today what
does it take to come up with a maneuver
like what would the monk O'Laughlin
maneuver or the Neel maneuver be because
I feel like well I have I got a I got a
maneuver bets again it's a lovemaking
yes okay okay so he had to make it
youtube that's it man I mean it was it's
crazy to be that scared and that
affected by seven and then just to sit
in three different positions and it get
better here's what I would have done
okay
when it got better I would have been so
relieved but when it was happening I
would have thought that it so
I would have been like this is it I got
a tumor or something you know I'm saying
like I immediately just jumped to the
worst possible conclusion that's what my
hypochondria does and so I don't think
that I would have gone a full day
without going into sync oh that night I
would've been like Jessie we got to go
at the emergency room I just gonna sleep
it off yeah I want it done it
goodness slipped hashtag ear biscuits
let us know how your year starting out
or whatever you ever you want to respond
to this and next week yeah we're getting
into it next week again it's it's gonna
be we're gonna talk about things we've
never talked about before that may or
may not interest you but we're gonna
talk about to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]